more proof democrats are officially the
party of the woke a new poll shows a
seismic shift in the electorate
democrats are increasingly identifying
as highly educated hoity-toity types who
will check you for using the wrong
pronouns while republicans are
attracting a more diverse working-class
base
and it's really no wonder voters are
abandoning the democratic party check
out this little exchange senator josh
hawley facing off with a berkeley law
professor greg went there over who can
get pregnant watch you've referred to
people with a capacity for pregnancy
would that be women
so
i want to recognize that your line of
questioning
is transphobic
and it opens up trans people to violence
by not recognizing that wow you're
saying that i'm opening up people to
violence by asking whether or not women
are the folks who can have pregnancies
do you believe that uh men can get
pregnant
no i don't think so you're denying that
trans people like this thing and that
leads to violence is this how you run
your classroom are students allowed to
question you or are they also treated
like this
opening up people to violence we have a
good time in my class
greg how do you think that class is
really oh my god if you
you went there yes that's you you better
be in lockstep or you're dead this is
you know what you're seeing there for a
specific issue is the end of debate when
you were faced with someone who wasn't
arguing a point
but employing redefined words then you
can't debate them because the word they
use is invented based on an artificial
reality which is pregnant man pregnant
man is a fallacy it's a fallacy it's not
real but you need but you can't even go
further on the debate because she's
saying no that's the final say i've
invented this word it's it's real and
this is an issue in all debates with
wokesters you can't get them to address
their own invented terminology instead
they throw the terms at you and say
that's how it is think about it though
when was this was uh during a hearing on
abortion i believe when was the last
time we actually had a debate on
abortion and not i'm not talking about
the arguments about choice or autonomy
or limits but the act of abortion itself
like a real philosophical public debate
on on uh on what is life when does life
begin what does science have to say why
don't we do that i don't understand why
we're always debating about
the choice which is which is rhetoric or
about the late what is we never actually
talk about the thing it's like going
into going to a car dealership terrible
analogy and you want to buy a certain
car but the guy keeps telling you
pointing you with other cars no i just
want this tell me about this and no one
wants to do it why is that it's just too
frightening i guess and if you
think about what we just talked about at
the top though if if you're seeing that
as a regular
middle class person in indiana and you
see someone out there talking about
transphobic violence
are you going to vote for the democratic
party if they're associating with a wing
nut like that well that's what's so
interesting about this this shift that
we're seeing in the country and about
this pool because what it's showing is
that uh a lot of you know regular folks
cannot relate to that conversation at
all at all and they look at josh hawley
and they're like yes he's just asking
the very reasonable question of uh you
know
you know it goes back to also like what
is a woman you know during the supreme
court hearings and you start having a
conversation most people across the
country go what this is ridiculous talk
to me about something that is relatable
that means something to them when you
talk about what's happening in the in
the electorate you see
that there is the elite the elite party
has become
the democrat party and i started to see
this shift in 2016 right you started to
see that the you know the signs for
hillary clinton were on the front lawns
of you know some of the best you know
most wealthy neighborhoods in the world
in the country um and then you know the
bodegas were putting up signs for
president trump and you've seen this
shift with hispanic voters you've seen a
shift with black voters and you see that
people want someone to meet them where
they actually are instead of talking
past them and i think that president
biden has gotten caught up in this web
in a way that is not helpful to him now
he's got this progressive group doing
this hashtag don't run joe and they
backed him last time around because they
feel like he hasn't you know he's not in
line enough he you know like is gonna
get kind of smacked around by this kind
of conversation and he has a moment he
has a choice to decide whether or not
he's going to put himself back in that
moderate map and get back to what he was
all about in the first place um we
haven't seen that happen yet but i i
think some of these numbers ought to be
you know put in front of him by people
who really you know who really care
about him and really want him to to if
they really want them to run again i
don't know
whatever percent it is
how dangerous is this this this
migration into the hoity-toity land of
uh of postgraduate degree uh gender
neutral situation that you guys are
drifting into when most of the country
um you know high school degree uh
working class people people that joe
biden won back right in 2020 he did
better with white working class voters
than hillary had done than barack obama
had done not more well we'll see we
haven't gotten to the election yet
there's a lot of time we haven't even
had the midterms um but about you know
the impact of these wokester moments
first of all the average person is not
watching these hearings and the average
person thinks of josh hawley and they
remember him fist in the air walking by
the people who became the capitol hill
rioters on january 6. josh hawley ron
desantis tom cotton they're all fake
they're populist fakes they all go to
ivy league schools they're fancier than
i am for everyone likes to make fun of
me for my ivory tower background and i
want to read something from the
washington post they're fancier than you
are they're fancier than i am
fancy
okay
let me read this i like that monica has
in the washington post if you know
you're talking about a pregnant woman by
all means call her that if you know
you're talking about someone who is
pregnant and not a woman then address
them how they want to be addressed
you're going to you're gaining just
seven extra syllables and i promise you
you're losing nothing and there is
something to treating people with
dignity i don't care if you
think that trans people are ridiculous
that it's made up whatever it is if
there's a trans man who is living his
life like this if he identifies that way
if he works a good job he has a family
and he wants to go and
have children the the greatest gift that
he can and he has not had gender
reassignment surgery okay then call him
how he lives
you're drifting
but that is not what we just saw with it
no it's not what you saw was if from
that law professor if you don't agree
with me and regurgitate the language
that i say you have to use it
you're stoking violence and you are evil
and we witnessed in that one little clip
which the whole world will see because
it was on the five on display is how
this left-wing lunacy germinated and how
it spread universities and colleges
students have been force-fed this and
threatened by these dictatorial
professors that if they did not
regurgitate this claptrap
in school you're not getting your degree
and out of school when they enter the
private sector and then you have the
consultants that are making millions of
millions of dollars every year selling
this garbage to people across the
private sector this is how it happens
and regular folks who want their kids to
get really good college educations watch
that and go am i paying or borrowing a
hundred grand to get a law school degree
from that woman
am i going to pay
a four year undergraduate degree out of
state is 300 000 and it's not berkeley
it's literally every single university
in college across this country that's
what you get for your degree no more no
more i have a question that i has
anybody ever asked how many
how many pregnant men are men are there
how many how many
do we know
ten i don't have the number seven how
many so leave them alone
we're being compelled to change our
language for seven people ten people a
thousand people i'm sorry you don't
change the language you don't take the
the the pronoun they and describe it to
a single person that's looting and then
saying we're being violent if we don't
use that language
a lot more people who i identify as
non-binary than those who are trans men
that are going to become proud
yes they do and so
you know most people are
respectful of people's choices in life
and when they look at this they say like
you know what when you know yes when
confronted with the situation i believe
most people are respectful i'd like to
see xxx or xy xx or xy don't be a
science denier all right so josh hawley
desantis tom cotton we're going to be
reaching out to you to see your
statement on whether you're fancier than
our resident liberal jessica
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now